the gyro can experience yeah
that's saying I know how to cook like
like killed animals and [ __ ] like that
cuz I ain't good at that yeah I still
wanna learn how to how to clean a deer I
want to learn how to do that type of
[ __ ] but but for the most part I can get
some fish I know other fish yeah well on
the Bahamas that's why you didn't need
anyway right yeah eat chicken chicken
chicken and fish chicken fish and you
could probably up chickens just run
around there's no predators right
snakes what if I singing that there it
might brought me you know rich mother
might be bringing some type of animal
look there they put pigs and water and
[ __ ] oh that's right oh that's right
those are that's the place where it is
that the Bahamas where all the wild pigs
are they come up people feed them yeah
it's a tourist but now I've advised to
go there it would used to be just me and
the peaks you know really how long ago
was that about five years ago when I
first started cause that's the first
place I went back when I started smoking
when I start smart I want to go
everywhere I went before and get have it
tomorrow and that [ __ ] was one of the
places where they have wild pigs
swimming around the tourists you get
tours there really it's just like in
scuba diving they start just throwing
[ __ ] in the ocean what like like little
statues and [ __ ] throw the notion and
you go look at it and people be
successful pictures oh so they put it in
there and to try to get more people to
scuba dive yes [ __ ] yeah and then it
ended up become a coral reef and [ __ ]
like that over time so it kind of is
good but at the same time is really
that's the only reason why they put it
in their pay for people to pay for tour
so weird way to get people just throw
pegs in the ocean it's weird that people
will go all over the country yeah people
I've heard people talk about in LA
pictures of my Instagram own little pigs
those pics of [ __ ] you up to if you have
if you around them you don't feed them
they'll bite you in your ass that's a
pig baby [ __ ] mother [ __ ] picking them
up taking pictures you know that's so
dangerous yeah
they be [ __ ] with them they got to
stop but I be seeing them trying to they
be trying to get them drunk and [ __ ] you
gotta stop that
come on come on so they feed those pigs
every day is it that like a daily the
tourists do but it means so many
tourists coming there they give them
stuff throw them little brandy so
they're almost tame oh yeah they kind of
they kind of involved with it and they
they used to they come in this swim
teni got iguanas on there I think
Nicholas Cage used on that island but he
probably sold it look at that yeah I
took that picture that's a great picture
right do they get food what they eat out
there oh jeez like that's all I know so
it's just what the people give and they
you have tourists tourists some tourist
boats every day I wonder how they
control their population how they keep
them from exploding what you mean pigs
make a lot of babies
yeah and they eat them would be right
next oh the people on the island you
okay they steal pigs I guess I mean yeah
I still break it yeah so they feed them
that's kind of a wild way to grow home
okay [ __ ] look like a tiger I
just looked at this one you look like
Tiger pigs they do it weird yeah you
know that happens with regular pigs if
you let them pigs do look nasty but they
so [ __ ] good mean delicious like the
bacon yes
good is [ __ ] I had some bacon recently
from pigs that they gave chocolate milk
and hazelnuts to they fed up chocolate
milk and hazelnuts and do it taste
better was I don't know I don't think so
I think it just tasted like bacon it's
like a Ferrero Rocher bacon forever
those little things are called this for
I don't know how to say it it's a
hazelnut chocolate thing like that okay
yeah yeah I know it's a rare Roche yeah
okay yeah I don't know I don't I can't
really determine what that tastes like
but it was just bacon pigs have a lot of
babies man what's weird about the pigs
is they're all one thing like wild pigs
and domestic pigs are all the same thing
Hulk yeah they just get weird when they
go when they get wild their body changes
the hair grows longer their nose grows
longer the tusks grow longer just from
being wild and it happens like
immediately they could be out there for
a couple months so just naturally does
that
taking the domestic Pig you let him go
and live in a wild when he knows he's on
his own
there's a shift that happens in his
biology and his hair starts growing
thicker and his nose going longer that's
what scientists can use there's
something for people that's what I like
us right because we go out there we just
gonna naturally grow horns and what
we're gonna get meaner we're gonna we're
gonna revert back to what we used to be
when we had a hunt and gather yeah and
people mad at us
yeah as we good
[Applause]